hey 42 here chimpanzees can identify
each other by looking at photographs of
their bottoms welcome to RIF vultures
can turn a dead body into a skeleton in
under five hours the northern hemisphere
is 1.5 degrees hotter than the southern
hemisphere a lobster's brain is in its
throat in 1883 a man named Jack Ferry
crossed the English Channel on a
floating tricycle during his restoration
in 1982 the Statue of Liberty's head was
accidentally installed two feet
off-center wherever a leaf is in the
world its internal temperature is always
21 degrees Celsius in 1990 there was no
roundabouts in the u.s. today there are
more than 3000 there is a 12% chance
that a game of Monopoly will go on
indefinitely the crunch of a crisp or an
apple in your mouth is a mini sonic boom
the Masters in lunacy where Victorian
officials who investigated whether
people claiming to be insane were faking
it the just mystic look was for people
who almost sailed on the Titanic two
weeks after it sank it had gained 118
thousand 337 members at any one time
there are a hundred thousand ships at
sea the first telegram sent on May the
24th 1884 by Samuel B Morse
read what hath God wrought blind people
are twice as likely to smell things in
their dreams as sighted people there are
60 people in Venezuela whose first name
is Hitler thanks for the view subscribe
for more for Caesar